eu estou aqui hoje porque há mais de dez
anos eu sou visitado por uma mesma
pergunta
e essa pergunta é a seguinte comuns como
pessoas comuns atingem resultados
incríveis nas mais diversas áreas
ou melhor como pessoas comuns atingir
resultados incríveis a partir de
recursos muito simples que sempre
estiveram disponíveis mas que a maioria
das pessoas simplesmente ignorado esses
recursos
a todo momento eu sou visitado por
exemplo do tipo como um homem sozinho
sem equipe sem recursos especiais deixa
nova zelândia larga tudo atravessa meio
mundo para os estados unidos estados
unidos um país supercompetitivo rico em
recursos pra quebrar o recorde mundial
de motovelocidade várias vezes a mais
que ano disse que esse homem é um
sexagenário pobre cardíaco meio surdo
tudo que ele tinha era um galpão onde
ele passava os seus dias mexendo nessa
moto com mais de 20 anos de uso
hoje a velocidade original não chegava a
90 quilômetros por hora e que utilizava
uma rolha da garrafa de conhaque como
tampa do tanque de combustível
como isso é possível
ou como professor a partir de 27 dólares
que o banco esse banco hoje empresta
dezenas de bilhões de dólares em
diversos países do mundo
o mais interessante é que os clientes
deste banco eles não assinam contratos
eles não oferecem garantias porque são
pessoas carentes ele criou um banco para
pessoas carentes que não têm garantias a
oferecer o professor que virou banqueiro
ainda ganhar o prêmio nobel da paz 27
dólares ou como ugandês que fugiu do seu
país é por conta de uma sangrenta
ditadura que se instalou por lá
se torna acabou morando nos estados
unidos e se torna uma referência mundial
de sustentabilidade e tudo isso a partir
de um sabonete que deixaram no quarto do
hotel dele e que ele achava inadmissível
que fosse trocado todos os dias
qual é o segredo dessas pessoas o que
elas fazem diferente com a água que elas
bebem porque eu e outras pessoas também
querem entender essa fórmula
mas antes de contar o segredo dessas
pessoas eu quero contar uma historinha
do nilton bonder que é a seguinte a
idade média no vilarejo
uma criança foi encontrada morta
imediatamente acusar um homem de ter
sido assassinado e foi preso e ficou
desesperado ele era inocente e sabia que
tinha sido vítima de uma grande
conspiração que faria qualquer coisa
para que ele fosse enforcado bom
chegou o dia do julgamento eo juiz
associado aos conspiradores para
condenar aquele pobre homem que quis
fingir que daria a ele uma oportunidade
de demonstrar sua inocência e fez o
seguinte o senhor é um homem de fé ele
disse sim sim excelência sou um homem de
muita fé
então é muito simples eu vou escrever
num pedaço de papel palavra inocente em
outro pedaço de papel a palavra culpado
você mesmo escolher o seu destino
você mesmo dar a sua própria sentença
ótimo pelo menos 50% de chance né
errado o homem começou a sua frio porque
ele sabia que aquilo tudo é uma grande
encenação os dois papéis tinham
inscrição culpado as chances de 50%
acabado de cair para zero
estatisticamente não tem como ele sair
livre 10 porque o papel inocente não
existe mas com brilho nos olhos
ele avançou nos papéis pegou qualquer um
deles engoliu lógico todo mundo gritou
agora que nós vamos fazer como vamos
saber
calma basta ver o que diz o outro papel
que saberemos que escolhi o seu
contrário
um simples toque de sagacidade
ele transformou a certeza da condenação
na certeza da absorção da absorção e
transformou 0 em 100% e tudo que ele
precisou para fazer isso estava bem ao
alcance das suas mãos literalmente era
uma solução simples bom mas na vida real
as coisas não funcionam assim é no nosso
dia a dia no nosso trabalho nos nossos
desafios
há questões complexas desafios
aparentemente impossíveis não tem
soluções simples bem ao alcance das
nossas mãos não é mesmo
será eu vou dar três exemplos disso que
estou falando
o primeiro tem a ver com o fato de que
ainda no mundo hoje
a essa altura do campeonato mais de um
bilhão de pessoas que não têm acesso à
energia elétrica no malauí por exemplo
98 da população não têm energia elétrica
mas se houvesse uma maneira de oferecer
energia elétrica a populações de países
carentes num curto espaço de tempo sem
dispor de investimentos financeiros e
tecnológicos e de forma gratuita não
mudar isso não é possível oferecer
energia elétrica de forma rápida e
gratuita sem realizar investimentos
financeiros tecnológicos é uma equação
impossível mas apesar desse problema
atinge tantas pessoas em tantos lugares
do mundo
foi uma adolescente pobre do malawi que
encontrou uma alternativa para essa
equação aparentemente impossível
houve uma grande seca no malauí e ele se
lembra que o pai dele depois que muita
gente morreu
ficava parado em silêncio olhando toda
aquela terra devastada pela seca
ele pensou acho que o meu futuro vai ser
como o meu pai ele não tinha dinheiro
para pagar a escola então ele ficava na
biblioteca do vilarejo folheando livros
e revistas
e foi numa dessas revistas que ele viu a
foto de moinhos
momento ele pensou o moinho de vento
produz a eletricidade pode bombear a
água tá aí a solução que a gente precisa
para o nosso desafio para mudar nossa
realidade e partiu imediatamente o seu
projeto
ele pegou um pedaço de madeira uma
hélice velha de motor de trator um
dínamo velho de bicicleta que ele
encontrou no ferro velho e o resultado
depois de muito trabalho foi esse moinho
suficiente pra fazer acender quatro
lâmpadas e fazer funcionar dois rádios
quatro lâmpadas e dois rádios em uma
região totalmente desabastecida de
energia elétrica é uma grande revolução
aquele vilarejo tinha uma bomba d'água
mas não era usada porque não havia
energia então ele construir um segundo
morrinho e pela primeira vez aquela
comunidade tem acesso à água potável
outra grande revolução e outros moinhos
vieram outros muitos vieram para
transformar a realidade de forma
significativa amigos vizinhos etc
a equação é possível a solução era
simples
o recurso já estava lá mas a maioria das
pessoas simplesmente ignorando o meu
trabalho construir o im
imagino que tem dado muito trabalho o
segundo exemplo diz respeito ao fato de
que no continente africano ainda há
milhares de minas terrestres e dados de
períodos de guerra como se não fosse
suficiente a tragédia de crianças e
adultos morrendo ou sendo sofreram
amputações por conta dessas minas
as pessoas não podem implantar até fest
agricultável mas ninguém toca porque não
consegue se livrar dessas minas como os
países são mais carentes
eles ficam dependendo sempre de ajuda
internacional mas se houvesse uma
maneira de num curto espaço de tempo
eliminar essas milhares de minas
terrestres estão abandonadas em países
africanos de uma forma quase gratuita
não dá essa é uma equação impossível e
apesar desse problema de é incomodar
políticos e pessoas de várias partes do
mundo
foi um desenvolvedor de produtos que
nasceu na bélgica que mudou para a
tanzânia que encontrou uma alternativa
para essa equação
ele pensou o seguinte olha qual o
recurso que eu tenho aqui em abundância
gratuito que eu posso usar para vencer
esse desafio
ele viu muitos rápidos por lá e ele se
lembrou de quando ela era criança ela
brincava de treinar camundongos e ratos
são treináveis e olfato é o faro dos
ratos é superior ao dos cães ora se eu
posso usar cães para farejar drogas ou
encontrar pessoas embaixo dos escombros
eu posso usar ratos pra dizer onde estão
essas minas terrestres
utilizando faro e uma vez que eu
encontrei um lugar da mina retirar não é
o problema retirar é fácil então ele
criou um método pra ensinar pessoas
treinar em ratos para encontrar minas
terrestres
o problema é impossível a solução já
estava disponível mas sendo ignorada por
muitas pessoas imaginam que demonstra o
trabalho treinar ratos terceiro e último
exemplo bom pouca pouca gente aqui deve
se lembrar mas em 1989 houve um acidente
na costa do alasca com um navio
petroleiro chamado edson valdés
o edson valdez despejou na costa do
alasca é milhões de litros de óleo
desastre ambiental total
apesar de se ter investido mais de 2
bilhões de dólares até hoje é possível
encontrar petróleo do exxon valdez na
costa do alasca
a empresa conseguiu tirar mais ou menos
só 18% do óleo
bom então vamos criar uma equação
impossível esse problema como num curto
espaço de tempo eliminar todo o óleo da
costa do alasca e ainda por cima
economizando boa parte dos 2 bilhões de
dólares para se isso fosse possível
alguém já tinha feito bom não dá pra
fazer
apesar desse assunto pelo papel desses
especialistas biólogos foi um
cabeleireiro do alabama que encontrou
uma alternativa pra isso
problema ele estava assistindo pela
televisão as imagens do acidente e viu
as lontras impregnados né com a pelagem
impregnada de óleo
nossa parece que quer que a pelagem das
lontras absorve óleo
eu trabalho com o cabelo nephasth
tintura no cabelo até lembra às vezes o
cabelo cheio de tinto para ser a que
cabelo humano também absorve óleo e ele
fez uma experiência muito simples
ele recolheu os cabelos que estavam no
chão do seu salão de beleza colocou
dentro de uma meia pegou um balde cheio
de água
jogou no bairro de quatro litros de óleo
lubrificante e jogou a meio com cabelo
dentro do balde o resultado
em dois minutos a água cristalina um
teste em larga escala mostrou que 630
mil quilos de cabelo teriam resolvido em
duas semanas o que o edson valdés não
resolveu em 30 anos e economizando boa
parte dos 2 milhões de dólares
bom mas nós vamos arrumar 630 mil quilos
de cabelo essa é uma outra história essa
é uma outra história mas a solução para
esse problema existe a equação é
impossível a solução recurso dessa
solução era simples já estava lá mas a
maioria das pessoas simplesmente
ignorava
então a partir desses exemplos nós
podemos dizer o seguinte sim também na
vida real
equações aparentemente possíveis
problemas que parecem insolúveis podem
ter uma solução simples bem alcance das
nossas mãos com recursos já disponíveis
para isso
2 qualquer pessoa tem a capacidade de
resolver equações impossíveis no
cabeleleiro um garoto pobre qualquer
pessoa
o desenvolvedor de produtos isso não é
monopólio de pessoas com cinco phds que
fala cinco idiomas ou estudaram nas
melhores universidades
as pessoas com essa capacidade de
transformar o que parece impossível
impossível estão aqui hoje elas estão
dentro das empresas das organizações
onde a gente atua elas estão dentro das
nossas casas prontas para utilizar essa
capacidade de mudar a realidade de modo
extraordinário bom mas se todas as
pessoas têm essa capacidade porque só
algumas poucas utiliza
é verdade só 5% das pessoas utiliza sua
capacidade de transformar algo que
parecia impossível impossível
muito se fala em desperdício mas esse é
o maior desperdício do mundo
vocês já imaginaram quantas
transformações nós teremos na sociedade
e no mundo se em vez de cinco função
fosse 15 30 40% das pessoas
viveríamos num outro mundo muito mais
próspero
o que essas pessoas fazem diferente
qual o segredo dessas pessoas bem após
dez anos analisando observando e
pesquisando essas pessoas
a boa notícia é que a grande diferença
entre ela e as celas e as outras está no
campo das atitudes e é uma boa notícia
porque a atitude a gente pode mudar
agora a principal diferença está mesmo
no campo de partida
no momento em que essas pessoas vão
definir quais são seus desafios quais
são as suas metas
as suas equações impossíveis para as
pessoas do grupo dos 5 por cento um
objetivo uma equação precisa ter alguns
ingredientes
ela tem que estar repleta de propósito e
significado
ela tem que ser relevante e
transformadora e ela tem que despertar
uma ligação emocional com quem vai
resolver essa equação impossível porque
quando esses elementos estão reunidos a
pessoa tomada pela curiosidade e quem
está tomado pela curiosidade não
descansa
elas não querem falar sobre outra coisa
elas não querem estar em outro lugar
elas querem somente continuar se
dedicando aquela equação impossível
aquele desafio e aí produzem 10 vezes
mais que uma pessoa comum só até dez
vezes mais criativas einstein dizia eu
não tenho nenhuma grande talento não tem
nenhum grande talento mas eu tenho
imensa curiosidade porque essas pessoas
não querem fazer outra coisa elas não
encontram caminhos e trilhos trilhas
prontas então elas acabam criando coisas
inéditas até porque elas não têm medo de
serem ridicularizados dizendo olha estou
treinando ratos ou estou recolhendo
cabelo pra
atuar ambientalmente já tentaram
perseguir uma meta com esses elementos
uma meta inspiradora oferece uma pessoa
média uma meta inspiradora uma pessoa
comum que devolverá um resultado
extraordinário bom
o garoto pobre do malauí e hoje
participa de conferência sobre o clima
ele se formou nos estados unidos
escreveu um livro que é de leitura
obrigatória em diversas universidades
americanas e quem quiser saber mais
sobre ele basta acessar o ted porque o
depoimento dele está aqui
bom o desenvolvedor de produtos que
nasceu da bélgica criou uma onde essa
ong tenta multiplicar esse conhecimento
esse método de treinar ratos que já foi
usado em mais de dez países mudando a
realidade de modo extraordinário e
ajudando as pessoas a vencerem a fome eo
o cabeleireiro do alabama cabeleireiro
do alabama patenteou a sua idéia já
criou alguns produtos que já estão sendo
usados em vias navegáveis para a
despoluição é e se descobriu que o mesmo
cabelo pode ser usado até 99 vezes no
processo de despoluição e uma ong foi
criada para lembra quando ele falou com
jackson uma tanto cabelo uma ong foi
criada para recolher cabelos pelos
salões de beleza para que quando alguma
coisa parecida vier a acontecer tudo já
esteja pronto
uma equação impossível repleta de
propósito e significado que seja
relevante e transformadora que cria um
vínculo emocional com quem vai resolver
esse desafio
esses são os ingredientes que fazem com
que pessoas comuns transforma em atinjam
resultados incríveis
por isso é urgente fazer com que um
número cada vez maior de pessoas utiliza
essa capacidade de transformar a 0 em
100% nas mais diversas áreas
utilizando recursos que já estão
disponíveis porque como nós vimos quando
uma única pessoa encontra grandeza toda
a sociedade evolui todo mundo ganha
porque o impacto das ações dele deles é
muito grande
como fazer isso
essa é a minha equação impossível
obrigado
[Aplausos]